You're probably used to seeing
in writing the code here,
to create an object,
an array, and function.
These are in the literal format.
These lines down here produce
the same end result, but
are in the constructor format.
The constructor format for each of these
is not recommended for several reasons.
It's not readable, it can be harder
to work with, and it's slower.
But the constructor function does offer
one benefit over a function literal.
It can dynamically create
a function at run time.
Remember that underscores template
functions job is to construct
a function.
It does so by using
the constructor function format.
Here is a function that takes two
numbers and adds them together.
It's written in the literal format.
This function does the same thing, but
it is written using
a constructor function.
The last argument to a constructor
function is the body of the function.
Any arguments before the last one will
become parameters for the function.
This makes constructor
functions really handy,
because they can create functions
with a dynamically supplied body.
So addr1 results in 3 and
addr2 gives us 7.
This make function accepts one argument
and returns a newly created function.
I'll call make and
pass to it the string fun.
This returns a new function.
This is fun function is waiting
to be called with some data.
If I pass biking, I'll get the string
biking is fun returned to me.
Passing in climbing, or
broccoli, makes them fun too.